i'd be willing to make a bet
a gentleman's bet
that if kim jong-un did an interview
with say i don't know dave rubin
he would be allowed to say basically
anything he could talk about how he wins
all the elections fair and square in
north korea how everyone loves him it's
all perfect there's no corruption gulags
don't exist and there's no suppression
of people's rights none of that youtube
would have no problem with him saying
literally whatever whatever he wanted to
say i mean obviously if he made direct
threats against the person take him down
but i bet if he also started talking
about how you know uh
making claims about war and and and
their missile tests and just lying
youtube wouldn't care
if donald trump comes out and says
things you may have seen dave rubin
interviewed him he just says he's huge
bleeps and he's like you're gonna have
to go off platform to watch because
they'll actually just take down the
video
it's strange how that works and joining
uh we've got a couple different guests
today of course we have china uncensored
uh joining and we've had you guys before
so thanks for coming back but we have a
special guest north korean defector who
actually just told me that the woke are
crazier than north korea was yeah wow so
young me park is here do you uh so we'll
learn all about your story and we'll
have a general conversation about the
region and north korea do you want to
just uh briefly introduce yourself
yeah uh
where do i even look at
so many people name where you're from
and why you're left so my name is jeremy
park
i was born in north korea northern part
i escaped in 2007 into china
after two years of
slavery in china unfortunately i had to
cross the gobi desert to mongolia by
walking
wow then i in 2009 that's where i flew
to south korea from mongolia wow and i
came to america in 2016 earlier to go to
columbia university new york wow suffice
to say it's really nice in america
america is great
[Laughter]
we have our problems oh yeah massive
problems wow well we definitely i
definitely want to hear about this and
you know the comparison between what's
happening in america and obviously the
hardships you've gone through and of
course we've got china uncensored shall
we start with yeah whoever wants to
introduce themselves
uh i'm shelley i'm the humor ninja for
china and censor
and i'm chris i host china and censor
and america uncovered right on yeah so
we have a we have a lot to talk about i
guess
how about we just talk about
north korea we'll start with that
what about it
how how is it i've seen i saw i remember
seeing this uh video before
actually i'm i'm i'm forgetting my my
place here guys you gotta smash the like
button you gotta go to timcast.com yes
you gotta become a member and subscribe
to all of our content because we have a
bunch of awesome content uh coming up in
the future we are going to be doing
another vlog tomorrow at cast castle
plus we've got the paranormal show
beginning and some stuff about
searching for lost confederate gold is
on the list so uh yeah yeah go to
timecast.com like share subscribe it's
friday we chill on friday we're gonna
have some some conversation so let's
just get into the conversation so
i saw this video that went viral that
claimed it
reportedly it was made in north korea
talking about homelessness in the united
states yeah and it was saying like look
how bad it is in america with all these
people who don't have homes and north
korea isn't like that yeah so i guess
we'll just uh
start starting with this right
how clearly there's uh an internal view
of north korea and a view that people
there have of the united states and then
from that your experience
you know so how about we just how about
i just start over and say
what was it like growing up in north
korea why did you want to leave
so
north korea or mostly when i describe it
it's not like even different country
it's like a different planet wow right
they don't in this 21st century they
don't have
electricity
right and they if you look at the
satellite photos it's the darkest place
on earth like literally
so i say like we have earth day every
day in north korea
very good for the environment
and we don't even know what internet is
like people have no clue right and they
don't have any other information so
north korea literally calendar begins
when kim your son was born
now when the jesus christ was born right
and they don't even tell us that we are
asians
they say uh you are kim your son race
really yeah
that's the the racism or
you know the highest so
they do not let you know what the house
would look like and i didn't even not
know africa different continents i never
seen the map of the world wow all i knew
was north korea
americans but they say american bastards
that's like a one word really yeah so
how did you know that you had it bad or
how did you know that you wanted to
leave
i did not know i had a bad because i i
remember they were showing us these
footages of americans and showing the
homeless people right and they look at
america there's no birds because
everybody ate the older birds so i heard
that yeah
we didn't though um actually that's not
that's that's not completely untrue
what was it the passenger pigeon
you guys know this yeah they used to go
out with nets and just catch pigeons and
then eat them and they drove it to
extinction interesting so that actually
happened but we we do have a lot of
birds and there's pigeons everywhere
yeah like there's pigeons on boats
exactly
yeah so so what happened
and they show they they cannot they like
eat the snow because they are so hungry
basically they are describing what we
are having in north korea
and
and then in schools like that like they
say there are four american investors
you killed two american ambassadors the
higher american ambassadors left to care
then as a younger you said two american
ambassadors so even though when they
teach you math it has to be propaganda
interesting everything has to lead to
one thing it's brainwashing us wow so
north korea is like apparently a
religion it's a kingdom right yeah they
keep your sons of parents were
christians so he copied the bible said
i'm a god i love you so much so i'm
giving you my son kim jong-il
his body dies but no no he's experienced
with us forever therefore he knows what
you think how much hair you in your head
wow i mean if the people believe in
bible i mean why would you blame people
not believing that right because they
cut out every information so people do
not know even what is critical thinking
is so how did it come to be that you
decided to leave hunger i was 13 years
old uh i was luckily by then i was
living this border town and at night
time i could see lights coming from
china and i was thinking
maybe if i go build a light store i
might find something to eat wow
i did an interview with some new
zealanders
who rode motorcycles through north korea
into south korea have you ever did you
ever hear of them no
so they organized what these individuals
wanted to do was
travel motorcycle they wanted to ride
motorcycles along famous routes so they
did like the silk road they did the
coast of south america
and then they they wanted to do
through north korea into south korea
there's no real roads to do it through
so it's very difficult
but they were telling me how
when they went through there they were
saying like this is what they explained
to me and so this is hearsay and i just
well you know you can correct me
that if there was like a farm
and a cow died yeah they couldn't eat
the cow no that someone would have to
come and take the meat and spread it
around the country evenly to everybody
or something like that no
what would happen so north korea there
are three it's a cat system they began
with the communism right let's make
everyone equal but now they got ended up
with 50 different classes within the
same people 50 yeah wow they divide
three big categories and they divide the
subclasses to 50 different classes and
you never can go you can only go down so
that's how they prevent people mixing
around being married there's no like you
marry up if you marry somebody in a
different class you go down with them
you don't go up with them wow so in that
case so if the so
one of the execution that my mom saw was
this young man he had tb tb is a huge
problem in north korea managing
tuberculosis yeah so he uh ate the cow
in the farm and then they were executing
him
for eating for eating meat yeah so i
never eat beef in my life because uh
cows are supposedly working the farmers
so you don't have a private property
nobody can own anything we cannot own
house we cannot own cars house nothing
we can own right it's a communism so you
own nothing and you must be very happy
yeah that great reset looks better every
day doesn't it really it completely
freezes you yeah
liberation you own nothing yeah so
this if the cow dies of course the
officials got to come and take it for
them and if the normal people eat it
you're gonna be executed what do they do
with the cow the official type elites
they divide with themselves
so they they take it for like the upper
caster yeah uppercast takes it and they
call even the tracking thing is like
this uppercase don't even call normal
north koreans are people they call us
like trash rubbish what that's how we do
north korea different cats treating each
other
wow is that because of like uh like
historical family things like oh you
weren't part of the revolutionary party
and that's how you end up in a lower
class so this is like what like made me
very sad america is like here all about
white girls like your ancestors on the
slaves be there for you must be guilty
and you are privileged in north korea
the same thing because maybe my great
great great grandfather was a landowner
or
not fighting for the communist side
then they said your blood is tainted
forever
now my how do you choose your ancestors
right you can never do that how do you
choose your skin guard you cannot do
that and so they punish you by being
associated to that it's called guilt by
association right i mean
we're we're going through this and it's
getting worse yeah so i i definitely
want to talk about the comparison
between wokeness and stuff but we'll
we'll get there so
you were 13 and you were hungry yeah and
you saw china and you decided to leave
so how long did it take what did you do
from there
so
i was initially gonna go with my own
sister who was 16 years old i was 13
and then one day i got really sick so
they took me to hospital and by north
korea we don't have like electricity
x-rays right doctor just literally rubs
your belly
and then nurse is using one needle to
inject everyone wow people don't die
from cancer in north korea we die from
hunger and infection mostly
and then they operated on me that day
without any anesthesia and then they
said it's appendix but it's okay people
cut bones in oscar with any anesthesia
it's a common thing
so i woke up and they were like no you
see you got malnutrition and infection
inside you
and
they closed me back and then i i could
not go right i might mostly die from
infection so she had to leave so she
escaped first with her friend
and then was there retaliation from the
government for your family it was too
quick and the another thing is that in
north korea a lot of people die from
starvation so they say oh i'm gonna go
to work and then father leaves home and
he doesn't come back and he died on the
road to work
so this appearance is a very common
thing for the people you know death is
like always near i mean you see the
death bodies on the streets every day
it's like trash right
so
i never thought that was like you know
i'm normal i thought it was
in the morning when you go to train
station there like so many bodies left
died and then they just collected like
woods right they are very
bodies get very rigid and just put them
together and then they don't even
like bother to bury them just like put
on like on the one side
and you see like rats eating human flesh
you see these children chasing these
rats the eating human eyes first
then somehow these rats have disease so
children die then rats eat us back they
cycle between rats and kids eating each
other
yikes yeah okay so after the hospital um
you're still 13 at this time yeah and
then you know what's what happened next
so i found a note that she my sister
left me and said go find this lady she's
gonna help you to go to china so i that
was like right after i got out of
hospital i took my stitch i was like now
walking very well there but i went to my
mom to find her you took your own
stitches out no they did and then the
next day i
with my mom and to the lady we found her
and then she said oh i can help you to
go to china
but just don't tell them that you are
mom and daughter
and then just tell them you're older
than like 13 right they say you're maybe
18 or 19 and told to my mom you're like
35 she was in her 40s i had no clue why
they were doing that but which was they
were selling us wow and traffickers
yeah
so what so so what happens next
so i cross this frozen uh river yellow
river and i mean there are guards with
the machine gun standing there is gonna
shoot you if you cross but because the
human traffickers drive the guards we
were able to go
and as soon as we arrived in china the
first thing was my mom being raped in
front of me
but the thing is i never so there's no
sex education in north korea right i
don't even know the word sex by then i
don't even know what kiss was like
love doesn't exist we don't know the
concept of love in north korea
now that that sounds like the most
villainous thing i've ever heard yeah
they i mean we know love but it's only
love when we have love for the dear
leader of course in the reaching fund
but they do not talk about women's love
so i never heard my mom says like i love
you ever i never knew that was a word
that people used that that's something i
didn't know i mean i i still imagined
with all of the problems of north korea
people
you know i i this this vision of this
like dystopian world where the young men
and women run and embrace and they're
like if the guards find us it'll all be
over like human emotion still exists in
this place people still understand these
concepts but i suppose if the if if the
authorities the powers suppress
knowledge from you you can't have these
concepts so this is the thing like in
north korea there's no concept from
compassion we have no concept for human
rights liberty love you know all these
things it's like why georgia ever talks
about who controls the language
controlling those
right double speak they write a new
language for you so therefore you don't
you're not capable understanding this
concept that we know here
so now you leave north korea you find
yourself in china but you've been sold
to traffickers yeah so now you have
another problem yeah i know and this i
mean it it it sounds like that's
this is it's hard to quantify but it
sounds worse
no
hunger is the worst thing any i mean if
you don't you die yeah
so
in china i remember like they told us
they don't even bother to force us right
like oh if you don't want to be sold you
can go back to north korea
and
which would mean death yeah which means
you're gonna even if you don't get
caught you're gonna die from starvation
anyway and one thing that changed my
mind was for the first time in my life i
was seeing a trash can
and i did not know what it was right
what is that one thing and like where
you throw things like what is trash like
things that you don't need like what do
you mean you have things to throw away
that's when i was like i told my mom i
want to stay and they sold my mom for
less than hundred dollars
in 21st century
so you were separated from your mom yeah
and they sorted me for less than 300
and like because i was virgin and that
was something valuable in china so
that's how i got separate from everybody
and became alone so then uh how long
were you in the situation for
almost two years
yeah and that's when i brought my mom to
me i made a deal with the human
trafficker who bought me and i was gonna
kill myself but he said oh if you become
my mistress i'm gonna help you to get
your family
so i did and he brought my mom back from
a farmer that he sold
and he brought my sick father from north
korea oh wow so he then brought your
father and your mother into china yeah
or the mother your mom was in china but
your dad then came yeah and uh
so what happens next you know we'll just
we'll make our way to how you made to
america you know yeah i know it's a long
journey
but my father had this colon cancer he
got from the prison camp
and he passed away
before the beijing olympic in 2008 i
remember the world was celebrating but
like north koreans you have to be
invisible you are always scared to get
caught by the authorities so he passed
away i buried his ashes around 3 a.m in
the middle mountain i was 14 years old
and then
one year later we met missionaries
from south korea and they said
oh if you become christian we're gonna
help you to be free
and then i was thinking like why do i
have to keep believing in something to
be saved but you know you're so
desperate that didn't matter even if
they told me you gotta believe in water
i'm gonna believe in the rock water
whatever it was so i became christian i
i proved my faith to them and they told
us we gotta walk across the coffee
desert
and then if you're lucky enough not to
die from the cold because it was minus
40 degrees in february in the middle of
desert
and then if we don't get caught by the
cars
then we might survive so i don't know
the probability of making that journey
and now nobody going that mongolia what
is too risky is nobody does it so then
you went the mongolia route where did
you end up after after that
so after mongolia we were in the
detention center several months and then
they bring in mongolia
they were moving around and then they
brought us to south korea then they make
us go through this insane process of
screening like they check if you're spy
or not are you actually north korean or
not
and then they put us in this training
three-month program
and tell us that americans are not
bastards
[Laughter]
south korea is not colonized by america
like you know they tell us what like
bank tell me atm machine and i literally
thought somebody inside the machine gave
me money right never seen such a thing
and in north korea we don't know what
bank is
so just tell us how to take a subway
like zero's like we are like babies we
are adults but babies never seen
anything like this
when you uh first got out of north korea
were you surprised by the kind of foods
that they had in china yeah
it was shocking
like
yeah describe your experience what was
like the first thing you had or what was
the most shocking thing about it but the
thing is you think
when you are studying like thank god you
think you're gonna eat a lot but your
stomach is not useless oily fatty food
so i remember i was throwing up
constantly and i get because i never
seen this many cars and buildings in my
life north korea 90 70 percent of those
are not paved and only of them are in
pyongyang too so never seen a traffic
and everything like crosswalk right
so
i mean but the thing is also i lost
everything by the time i was in china
like i was a slave so it wasn't
i could enjoy anything there i was every
day was a survivor i remember like every
day i feel like i live thousand years
today
every day i goes by and before i go to
sleep i put on my shoes on
i always have to look for the excitement
the police comes where do i run where do
i jump so ready to run every single day
like you live like that so now you've
made it to south korea they put you
through this screening they want to make
sure you're not a spy but was there a
point where they finally opened the
doors and said
freedom is yours
yeah what was that like
scary
it was so painful so scary yeah
i mean like they remember i remember
they said like for the first time so
introduce yourself and in north korea we
don't say i like it we don't allow to
say i we said like we like water even
though when i say because
that's like the meme
it's not a meme's actually no no there's
there's a joke where we make fun of
communists by replacing the letter i
with we
oh they totally do that wow really yeah
and then like nobody asks you what do
you think in north korea right so they
tell you your favorite color is red
because a revolutionary color
your favorite country is north korea
because your favorite food is this right
so now in south korea they say oh if you
don't know just tell us your favorite
colors like what the heck is that
do i suppose know what's my favorite
color so thinking for yourself
was something not trained it was hurting
my brain
it was so painful literally saying
being free is not easy like if i was
guaranteed that i'm gonna have frozen
like enough potato if i go back to north
korea i would go back wow wow really it
was hard so like if if you if you could
have survived you would have chosen to
go back yeah
for sure in the beginning yeah in
several years time i would have gone
back it was very painful to be free but
you you you learned you figured it out
you adapted i adapted i i learned like
what freedom was you know it for me to
learn freedom was like responsibility
and once i made that connection it
became like under more manageable right
but it's scary like in north korea when
you're born
your life is determined for before
you're born based on your class your
parents everything so what do you mean
you choose your own major right like
they say what school do you want to go
to i don't know so what major do you
want to do what do you do with your life
i'm like do i have to know
can just somebody tell me what to do i'm
very good at like being followed it
seems like we're seeing uh this
transformation in the united states
where young people want exactly that
they want to be told what to do they
want the government to do it for them or
they've gone
a lot of young people especially the
millennial generation so not not not so
young anymore
in in like my life i was always told you
have to go to school you have to go to
college you have to do these things and
everyone kept trying to tell me what i
was supposed to do and for me i was
no i'm not going to do it but a lot of
people i know
went to college and just did what they
were told
when they get out of college they ask
now tell me what to do yeah so they're
not used to being out there in the
wilderness on their own and of course
this is very very very different from
say north korea
but it's part of this this shift i
suppose where we used to be
i mean americans are fairly obstinate
you know don't tell me what to do i'll
do what i want but we're starting to see
that shift now so we're really close to
getting into modern politics but so i'll
just ask you this so how did you end up
you know so you're you're adapting to
south korea at what point did you decide
now i'm gonna make an even bigger
journey and choose for myself to go to
america
oh
so i invited to a conference
that was uh in ireland
you know dublin and
and it was a free conference so they
wanted to it's like a youth leaders like
a leadership conference every country
participates so they asked north korea
they called up north korea ms in london
would you send a delegation from north
korea and then they said we only can
send three because you have to spy on
each other so two is a lot easier to run
but three like you're watching i'm
watching we are watching everybody right
so it's like we only can send three and
they're like okay how about we sponsor
two you sponsor one and recognize no so
they were like okay we're gonna bring
these defectors then it's cheaper for
them
very practical so they invite me for
free
and then
i decided to be a speaker i applied to
be speaker it was very hard to become a
speaker and the speech that i gave
became very very vital and i was in the
university in south korea so that led me
to write a book and penguin randomized
was in new york so they brought me to
write a book in new york and then i
wanted to continue my education and i
they told me there was a school at
colombia was in new york
so so here you are yeah that's how i'm
here so the interesting thing i suppose
now is that uh you come here you go to
college the the current culture war in
the united states is there's a very
negative depiction of colleges that
they're embracing critical theory
marxist ideology and wokeness sounds
like there's similar aspects to what you
experienced with um the ideology being
you know told what you can and can't
like and things like that not identical
obviously but well before the show you
said that the woke was crazier yeah i
think that's what i said i could be the
fox news like north korea is not even
this nuts
this is uh i mean where do i even begin
but i mean it just entire four years
i was
so in north korea by the time when i was
born the revolution happened such a long
time ago people
are not passionate believers of
communism right collectivism they just
so much fear if you don't you get
executed so you have to do it and like
one thing first thing my mom told me as
a younger was don't even whisper because
the birds and mice could hear you
and she was like your tongue is the most
dangerous weapon that you have the
things you say is not gonna just only
kill you it's gonna kill three
generations of our family or together so
be careful what you say right when i go
to school in the morning she would not
say i'll be careful with the strangers
be careful your mouth
i
i'm worried that we're headed in that
direction exactly you know with uh with
censorship with big tech with people
scared to speak out there are a lot of
people that say you know i i was
tweeting about anonymity i wasn't really
tweeting about anime but i was tweeting
about people who don't use their names
on social media and people said i'm
scared that i'll lose my job i can't
risk my job and my life from speaking
out
and if people
don't speak out we we slowly slip into
the nightmare
version of whatever that is where
the thing yeah the things you're
describing yeah this is how we go there
this is how it begins
wow yeah that's what i like at colombia
oh this is how the revolution began
right because
i mean at columbia this genuinely these
kids feel like they are so oppressed
they get triggered they actually cry
right by the injust they fear how they
are so oppressed and they are the
victims and they're not faking it they
really really truly believe in the thing
is what makes me so sad is that north
koreans have to be brainwashed because
we don't have any information
here on youtube of your finger you have
entire history what's stalling it what
the mao did you have know what this rod
has taken us to humanity but these
people are so completely brainwashed
they think white men are the source of
every single evil that we have
i suppose i think it's uh
scarier to me that you can warn us and
say hey this is how the revolution
started in north korea hey this is what
it's like when you have this communist
totalitarian system
and no matter how many times we scream
it there are a lot of people in this
country that reject the idea that your
warnings matter and they actively pursue
these situations i suppose they think
they'll be like the higher caste maybe
those who live in pyongyang
they have paved roads yeah they have
electricity yeah but they'll probably
just end up being the farmers and the
outskirts who are executed for speaking
out improperly oh yeah they get so much
purges in pyongyang so i think but the
thing is like north korea designed
starvation right it's like a hunger
games there are 13 districts and there's
a capital right on purpose kim jong-un
starves us like the other viking zone
admitted that 11 million north koreans
are severely managed he never did that
before but now he doesn't bother hiding
it like yeah we have like almost 60
people so 60 of the population are
severely malnourished why is doing that
because one missile test that he does he
can feed 25 million north koreans for
entire year
from 2017 he did a 40 test
why if we just cut down a few tests
nobody have to die in north korea why
i i don't so this is what i can't
understand and maybe maybe you'll you'll
have some insight having obviously been
from the country wouldn't it be better
for
the the party for kim jong-un for his
his close circle wouldn't they be
wealthier if if north korea was
successful and prosperous with a
well-fed population with new
technologies and electricity wouldn't he
live better and safer no but then he
cannot be a god
right right now
you think about it when you're full then
you are starting up a meaning of life
you can think it was philosophy music
art right but when north koreans every
day they don't care what's going on am i
gonna be able to find the next mirror or
not am i gonna make it tonight or not
that's all they care so people entire
population is dedicated surviving
so
now kim jong has no internal challenges
it's not like other countries there's
internal any region there's no one
single distance in north korea have you
ever heard that there's a house arrest
no
what's his what's his goal what does he
want
wasn't he educated in the west in
switzerland yeah it's a psychopath he
knows how humans should be treated
that's the thing like it's so he
recycled but he knows how people should
supposed to be treated but he doesn't
right he goes there
he's he thinks he's a god i think so
because a lot of people who met him when
they're younger they call him like
little janitor right yeah like so
everybody's like below him so i don't
think he's just completely himself
brainwashed that he's a god so do you
think the us is uh i mean the u.s is
massive
how many how many people uh do do we
know the population of north korea in
america or the population of north korea
do we do 25 million 25 million so i mean
the the us has about 10 times the
population
uh
it's it seems far far-fetched i suppose
or maybe people just believe it can't
happen here but
do you think that what you're seeing in
the u.s will bring us to a a situation
like north korea i'm like right now
living in chicago yeah i mean
this chicago is a war zone you cannot
even walk out either in the middle of
day in the downtown where there's police
cars right there people commit crime
and this as i mean you say system is
broke like literally during the lootings
right police standing there and this
guy's destroying nike store in the
magnificent maya and why don't you
arrest them and then my friend said like
why don't you arrest them and then he's
like i know who torres and this guy just
started shooting at him whoa police is
right and he had to run for his life
he has a video
i'm not joking like
oh my gosh he was started shooting at
him and police are standing there
nothing are you familiar with the red
salute
no have you seen the black lives matter
fist they show in the in the yeah is
that is that is that does that symbol
appear in north korea
i mean like during this thing yeah oh
yeah totally that's every time like
let's kill our american bastards our
enemies oh you raised the fist yeah so
this the the the it's the red salute
it's the communist fist um you guys
might know this i was reading that when
someone is joining the chinese communist
party they they perform the red salute
they call it yeah i mean you have to
like raise your fist and pledge your
life to the party essentially as yeah
this this uh well july first is the 100
year anniversary of the communist party
and there's this phenomenon of red
tourism where people are going around
dressing up like old red guards and
they're doing the salute and they they
go to get glitches you go take it you
know instagram photo of you doing the
red salute and pledging your life to the
party
you know that's disneyland that's the
flag of black lives matter
it's the it's the symbol twitter used
for juneteenth yep yeah and they say
it's the black power fest and i'm like
yeah i guess the roman salute which the
nazis used is the white powerful or so
whatever it doesn't matter to me i mean
these are these are these are salutes to
the ideology
and it's
oppressive
and uh i i don't want to be alarmist
yeah by saying oh it's clearly happening
here but you look at the embassies
flying these flags the u.s embassy is
now using these the the symbolism you
see people marching through the street
in defiance of edict from governors when
they did the lockdowns and they're
performing the red salute they give it a
different name but it's the same symbol
the same flag the people who are
organizing black lives matter say they
are trained marxists or at least some of
them do
and critical race theory which is the
big battle in the culture war right now
is uh literally rooted in critical
theory uh from the traditional marxist
school of thought
and they try and deny it
but
every day i i feel i do feel optimistic
especially today
with you know seeing these these
families loudoun county they're standing
up they're challenging this stuff
but
i i feel like
you know these people these these
families are worried about what their
kids are being taught are putting
themselves on the line i'm worried that
if too many people are scared
and they remain scared we inch closer
towards a reality where you can no
longer speak out anymore i mean we have
the poem we know what happens when you
don't speak out in defense of others
so it feels like we're we're heading in
that direction
i think there was a viral video of some
woman it was like a chinese woman who
was talking about i don't know if this
was allowed in her somewhere else but
yeah she was a like a chinese parent and
she was saying this is just like the
cultural revolution which i went through
in china and a lot of people kind of
were offended by that because they're
you know
possibly 20 million people died during
the cultural revolution so some people
are like oh well that's you're being too
crazy if you're comparing this to the
cultural revolution
but
you know
if you the the hallmark of the cultural
revolution was the struggle session
right which is struggle under chinese
communism is a verb where you struggle
someone you bring them into a room
everybody in their workplace or
everybody in the neighborhood like if it
was a very prominent person they would
fill stadiums to denounce these people
like the person would stand there they'd
be made to hold some kind of like
torture posed so that they're like the
airplane or something where they're like
uncomfortable they'd have like a placard
put on them that says what their crimes
are right and then people would scream
at them yell at them humiliate them
shame them throw things at them this is
a struggle session
and it's like well if you think of that
as what the cultural revolution was
doing to people
you know we don't struggle people in the
us
we cancel people in the u.s
yeah and we can cancel them online we
don't have we can ruin people's lives on
twitter we don't have to bring them into
a room
to yell at them we can just make them
lose their jobs
how is it that that you know china and
north korea are so different i suppose
right they went through a cultural
revolution they had purges they have a
communist party with the red salutes and
all that stuff but
china still has massive cities and
wealth and technology and food
probably a lot of that is just the
ability of china to accept investment
from the west
china really changed after mao died
uh mao because
you know his political purges basically
like killed
almost 80 million people
probably
so between the great leap forward the
famine the you know cultural revolution
like he he was just killing so many
people and then the next generation of
chinese leaders were basically like okay
we're communist but this is not
sustainable
so they kind of and a lot of them were
people who were purged by mao like xiao
ping so they were like we're going to
uh
open our markets they call it reform and
opening up and it wasn't really
the state was still involved like the
state still owned the means of
production but they were kind of like
we'll give people the ability to at
least make money on a small scale you
can have businesses
you don't have to work for the state
western investment can come in
and bring the money i remember reading a
story about like after mao died like the
first people who were like
made a contract
and like for them is like oh that we
might die
for this like we might be killed for
this it was like the first test of like
will this reform and opening up actually
happen so so what year was that around
1978.
so that's when they finally started i
guess modernizing and getting more
technology and things to improve and
then because china is such a massive
market there's so many people there to
work right manufacturing companies
wanted to come in companies germany came
in in the 70s to start like building
their volkswagen very early yeah so like
building their auto plants there already
and also people see it as a big market
where people can buy things now
so i think that's the real difference
but like
structurally it's not that different
from north korea
uh you know north korean people
ideologically and structurally people
like to pretend that china's not
communist anymore because they have
uh you know
a certain thing like they have a stock
market but
you can't own property in china still
wow like the state owns all the land
still you can buy a lease
on the land for 70 years interesting and
that's what you're buying when you buy
real estate or you can buy an apartment
in an apartment building but you cannot
actually own land all the land is still
owned by the state and there is no real
private companies it's it's maybe
state-owned enterprises otherwise it's
owned by a son or daughter of a party
official
or every company every school
everything in china basically has a
communist party cell inside of it and
there's a party secretary there watching
everything so the parties involved there
is no free enterprise in china isn't it
every single company has to have a party
member yeah specifically whose job is to
be a party member for the company or
something like that the party secretary
yeah yeah we're work work that's
happening here in the us with the uh
diversity inclusivity and equity
officers
in in all these companies i mean it's a
job that performs no no function other
than to be ideologically pure
well that's the that's a strange thing
about all this like i've seen some
reactions to like you're
like you own me talking about woke in
america and then and people get really
upset about that they know that's
ridiculous or as shelly mentioned the
chinese woman who's like hey this is
reminding me of the cultural revolution
and
if you only focus on like the
differences like obviously the united
states is not north korea
but
somehow those societies became the way
they were
there is an evolution that happens and i
think the problem is people don't
realize or understand what marxism is
they don't understand what communism is
like what is the problem of trying to
create an equal society what's the
problem of trying to teach people about
slavery that's not bad
so why are you saying that this is like
the cultural revolution
every i think every example
of the the path to the utopia turned out
to be a path to hell yeah
by design yeah right well i you know
what i think happens to i think there's
a
i know a lot of these activists on the
left and they're very
utopian they're very optimistic
idealistic and they're like we can
create this beautiful utopia so long as
we all just agree on how things work
well
it starts with 10 people them and their
friends and they all say hey i work
today and i'm going to share with you my
bounty and they say thank you very much
i did the dishes for you and then it
goes up to 20 people but then one person
says i'm not going to share with you my
you know my pizza i i made this piece of
myself it's only enough for me i'm
starving i'm hungry and they say okay
this person's got to go because no
matter what we say they won't agree with
us
when it scales up to a certain point and
you have
you you're now locked to borders of a
country
and you can't just say
we're going to leave and do our own
thing
well then what happens is they say you
know we have this really great utopia
except for those people
well what do we do with them
i guess you gotta get rid of them
and what ends up happening every single
time
they get rid of them
and there are people who will argue with
that but that basically is what it says
in the communist manifesto that to
create this equal utopian society you
have to overthrow
all pre-existing social conditions uh
like the family like religion well what
happens if somebody doesn't want to give
up their religion what if somebody likes
their family
what if they like private property
this is why i wonder about you know
north korea you know you're saying that
you don't have these concepts you don't
understand love and things like that the
color thing was
amazing like that that's something that
kindergartners
have you learn your colors what's your
favorite color yeah which one just do
you and i remember being a little kid
and they have a bunch of colors
and they're like which one is your
favorite and i'm like i don't know i
said green you know why because my
birthday's in march and the calendar for
march was always green
so i just said green like they just left
it upon me as a child who had no real
understanding of what it meant to have a
favorite color to just
say it yeah and i was like green clearly
green is not my favorite color today
[Laughter]
you know you you
a good point about that is like a lot of
the problem people have with like this
critical race theory stuff that's going
around especially when it's being taught
through like k through 12. like
whatever
it is as a university subject you're a
college student you're a fully foreign
person but like if you're talking in
kindergarten
you don't even have a real sense of your
own self-identity and yet you're already
being put into these classes
see
what's interesting
technically they aren't teaching
critical race theory because they're
arguing oh we don't bring up the
literature of race and policy what
they're doing
is they're teaching
the the core thesis of critical race
theory within other subjects
so imagine here's why i described it
imagine if a bunch of parents decided
that the new math curriculum would be
something like
here's a math problem a child encounters
jeremiah has 10 bibles in order to
worship the lord properly he must
distribute seven of them to his
neighbors if he doesn't he will burn in
hell how many bibles does he have after
he distributes the ones the lord
requires like if that was an actual math
problem in schools parents would be like
yo like
they're not teaching the bible they're
not teaching christianity no what are
you talking about not we've never
mentioned scripture nobody's reading
from the bible you're crazy and then you
look at the math you look at the math
problem you're like this is just this
whole thing
so they're finding subversive ways to
indoctrinate kids but it's also
incorporated in their policies and the
scary thing is become inherent now
where you have these schools that don't
even recognize they exist in this
alternate reality they just it's normal
to them
that's that's where that's where it
starts
like you mentioned these countries all
ended up these ways that's what i find
truly interesting uh so uh obviously a
lot of people know that i'm part korean
and uh because you know tim pool is
mixed race like a meme i say it all the
time because we're talking about you
know race policy and
identitarianism but uh actually my great
grandfather is from a city in the north
at the time there was no north so for my
family leaving korea coming to the
united states and all that stuff
these these concepts of a north and
south and this conflict didn't exist at
the time something happened where all of
a sudden
the city where my great-grandfather is
is
worlds apart from the city where my
great-grandmother was from and i think
my great-grandmother was from seoul and
my great-grandfather was from hey hi jew
hey june yes yeah now i mean at the time
they were probably identical in many
ways like same culture same language
same history now they're just absolutely
different oh yeah i'd imagine the people
in the north like you mentioned they
think they have this god they have this
new religion the history has changed
yeah something happened to make it that
way and now that that impacts you know
even me and and other people whose
history sort of stops at these these
conflicts the historical revisionism
that's happening in the united states is
what scares me and that's why i kind of
you know related to these circumstances
i mean north korea also had like a speed
run at this in a certain way because
it was the soviet union after world war
ii that got north korea right like the
treaty was we split it along the 38th
parallel that the
the western democracies they get south
korea
russia the soviet union gets north korea
so you guys kind of had like
like a crash course
in this in a certain sense where like
you know now suddenly kim jong
kim milson is put in
and he's like taking soviet stuff and
then using it to build his own
identity cult and all this stuff so it's
kind of it's kind of crazy to look at
north korea too because this is like
this is like the you know like the super
powered version of what happens i mean
the thing is like what shocks me about
north korea they began like communism
right promising oh i'm gonna give you
free health care free education free
housing free every i mean nothing is
free but they say everything is free
so they did that in the beginning from
the soviets they got subsidies so they
were giving rations to people for free
in the 90s they stopped the soviet union
collapsed what do they do they changed
their ideology to self-reliance
so now they don't care about you you
take care of yourself by the way you
have no freedom to trade do nothing so
how do you survive
that's why like 3 million people died in
the 90s in the northern parts
if you secretly grew
a tomato plant or something in your base
and like you hid it in your house would
they would they execute you if they
found it
no i mean if you hide it really well
yeah like let's let's say you're
starving yeah so you secretly grow some
plants it's okay it's okay yeah
yeah you're you're allowed to grow your
own food or no we cannot underline this
collectivism we work collectively in the
farm and then the government takes 80
percent and 20
is divided between the comment of
fishers and then they just start numbers
don't give you anything it's like the
stupidest thing i've ever heard to be
honest like it's an inefficient way to
run a system to even benefit themselves
i think this is why china was like hey
let's take investment we want to be rich
and successful now there's no there's
more chinese millionaires than there are
american millionaires they've made
themselves wealthy and powerful
why doesn't north korea do it
he's just getting too scared he's very
scared and all he needs is nukes right
so he's he doesn't want to change and
he's comfortable i mean he's been he's
been so good at this why would he change
anything right they've been so
successful at this for almost 80 years
they've been doing this and i think um
even kim jong-un is a victim of the same
brainwashing at this point
certainly he's in charge and he
understands it more and knows more than
regular people he was educated in the
west but he was also very much
indoctrinated you have to run this
country you have to be in charge and so
his world view is is now a product of
their own manipulation yeah it's kind of
crazy because i'm sure uh kim il-sung
had he had an understanding of global
affairs in world politics
he probably understood
you know he was marxist he was a lioness
for sure yeah i'm sure he but but he
knew about russia he knew about the
world and then he told everyone he was
god yeah and then
his son was in the 70s trying to
be nice to his father because he had a
lot of concubines and sons right so
there's a competition that came the game
of thrones remember
this happened in malaysia literally they
are killing each other to get there
so he was saying in the 70s oh i want to
get this throne from my father so now
i'm going to make him god so he did all
propaganda making him kim can move the
mountains knows what you think like
everything began there so so what are
the circumstances keeping north korea as
it is certainly there's external
pressure for them to change their ways
open up free their people but my
understanding is like china is very
defensive
china likes north korea as sort of like
this problem that the rest of the world
needs to come to china to work on
uh they're a crazy guy with nukes and
only we can negotiate like if you have
to talk to us and
it actually ties a lot into um sort of
china's internal political struggles as
well because certain factions within
china were the ones
working with the kim family
other factions
did not
so yeah it's it's it's
it's leverage for them yeah it's
leverage and it definitely makes china
look better
it really does
yeah well like hearing a story where you
say that that that you felt being a
slave in china was better because at
least you had food
but the thing is what shocks me is in
america like these people talking about
slavery that happened hundreds of years
ago right this is happening right now
when you're sitting down do you know
during the recovery time if you go to
buy to the chinese google you can north
korean girls for nine hundred dollars
you order them in
and this is happening and nobody in
mainstream like michelle obama has no
problem standing up for girls are
captured by isis or boko haram
where is any public figure in the
mainstream standing up for this curse
right now there are 300 000 north korean
refugees in china hiding and most of
them are women and most of them are
trafficked so we have actual modern day
slaves existing china has a huge human
trafficking problem yeah because the one
child policy screwed up the third
population
30 million more men men cannot find
wives so where do these women being
bought by these 30 million men who
cannot afford the wives in china wow are
there organizations that buy the women
to then free them and and get them to
other countries we do that i work with a
lot of non-profits we do rescue work but
it's become so hard on the covet oh yeah
so but the thing is it's you know now in
america right now there is only over 200
north koreans made it to america for
during the last 75 years
yikes yeah
for for you to come from south korea to
the united states was it difficult
i came as a south korean as so oh so you
walked right in yeah but then i had to
get a visa i mean i came legally yeah
all right like yeah
as a south korean you can just fly here
on like without notice and get visa on
entry right you get the electronic visa
but it's hard to get a working permit
right you can come as a tourist but it's
very hard to come as immigrate immigrant
from south korea yeah yeah it's actually
fairly difficult uh i think for anybody
to to to get a work visa in the united
states i say relatively difficult but
i'm sure there's a lot of countries
where it's a lot harder especially with
like middle eastern refugees into europe
i've seen a lot of those stories
yeah so yeah it's pretty closed off yeah
yeah yeah you know i've heard people say
that japan is an ethnostate and i've
heard other people say it's not but i'm
curious you know what you guys think
about that i'm not an expert on japan
outside of anime
[Laughter]
well so
i guess the difficult thing is i'd like
to try and predict the future you know
i'd like to know can we can we take we
we've made some of these statements like
oh we can see what happened in north
korea we can see how people behave how
they're scared to speak and then
we we we've said somehow north korea
became this way
but is it really like the u.s could
track in a similar direction or is it is
it just
fanciful thinking that the us would ever
become like this
you know
is the u.s going to break out of this
and just become
sane again and defeat the the cultural
marxist ideology i'm fairly optimistic
to be completely honest i mean i i see
these parents waking up i see
a lot of a lot of reason to be
optimistic in terms of what's happening
politically with people being snapped to
attention because of what's happening
and i have to imagine that there's
elements within the us government
they know everything we're saying and
they're worried about these things too
or
is the ideological split so severe that
these you know cultural marxist and
critical race theorists control too much
well i think with everything happening
in schools that's
that was definitely overreach like once
you start targeting people's kids that's
when people really freak out that brings
it to home
so i think this is
like all the debate about critical race
theory i think it's really a good window
of opportunity to
educate people about what marxist
ideology is how it functions how it
takes an issue and inverts it and then
flips it into something else like for
example race
uh you know decades ago
we as a country made a decision that you
know judging people by the color of
their skin is wrong that's racist and
now it's it's flipped so it's like oh no
no you should develop racial
consciousness i think the term they use
you need to be able to look at people by
race so you can properly sort them out
based on their privilege and their
oppressor status
that's creepy it is it's
it's kind of the opposite of taoism
actually
yeah
i'm curious about war
um we recently saw china send the most
warships they've ever warped warplanes
into the taiwanese defense zone
and so there's this
obviously one thing we mentioned often
is through city strap there's a very
real fear that war will be happening
soon i'm wondering before we start
talking about china though
this stuff that you see with north korea
with the firing of the nuclear missiles
do you feel there's anything to that or
is it just kim jong-un says look at me
i'm a nuisance give me free stuff and
there's not actually going to be any
real conflict out of the nuclear weapons
in north korea
i think kim jong is very rational enough
not to start a war with any country he
knows when he does that he can be done
right i'm not gonna get him so i don't
think that can ever happen but
it it just i think kim jong-un's uh goal
is waiting for the west to be weakened
right
for the west to be destabilized right
now there's so much internal problem
america is so busy with themselves right
now not able to solve any problems like
globally yeah so it's a good thing for
kim jong-un right he wants to beat
america and internally he just keep
building capability with the missiles so
someday his dream might get that he
might bomb america entirely
and i mean he's his bombs can reach
hawaii this yeah but you know bombing
few cities not gonna he's not gonna win
the war right he can attack damage the
usa but not gonna win but when america
is so busy just keep doing this his
thing if if he were to try and fire a
nuke or something would china china
would stop them right
uh china would be probably forced in
position where it would have to at least
offer some kind of lip service about
like that's bad yeah because they don't
want the
rest of the world to turn against china
right because like if you if you are a
country backing north korea nuking
some other country that's that's bad pr
yeah
um practically speaking what they would
do i
china is worried about north korea
becoming
a little
too hot to handle
too unwilling to listen to beijing
leadership
uh as i recall kim jong-un didn't even
meet with xi jinping for many years
until until
yeah trump was about to meet with him
and then suddenly like the two sides it
wasn't kim jong-un didn't want it sizing
pink didn't invite him do you know that
the uncle
he was a chinese guy he was funded by
china a lot the uncle who got executed
right oh yeah so when
kim jong-un killed his uncle china got
so upset because they just did it
independently
so
shimmy didn't invite him didn't like
accept him as a logic to minority leader
but when he wants to meet trump because
china had like jumped before didn't
wasn't the brother that kim jong-un
poisoned also like hiding in china he
was kind of being supported by china too
china has been trying to push like their
own interest in north korea by pushing
people who would make the kind of market
reforms yeah they want and supposedly
kim jong-nam kim jong-nam was open he
was open to that idea
so china always recommended north korea
to take our path your comments probably
gonna last forever and it's like open up
a little so people don't die from
starvation right like what's the point
of all this and those are like no no no
we're fine so kim jong-un get rid of any
reformers in the international land
china wants
north korea to to do better and adopt
some more of their kind of policies
exactly they won they they toured kim
jong-un the second game when he was
alive show them around look at us what
we have done like lucas online beijing
like two weeks tour show him like take
the reform like path
and then kim jong-un goes back nope nope
we're gonna hit that right this might be
a dark question but why isn't anybody
just removed that lineage and just
gotten rid of that family
i mean certainly there are people you
mentioned they're hiding out in china
even china's got interest in this
does no one want to i mean look people
have tried to
remove castro saddam hussein
the issue is china does not want a wave
of north korean refugees flooding into
china
interesting they don't want to be
responsible for north korea because it's
so
terrible right now like you have to
rebuild the society and they scratch
right and they can't let the us take it
yeah because if they don't the u.s walks
right in and they don't want the us on
their border yep
it's their buffer yeah so complicated
and so horrifying because there are
people here who need
food and resources and just more
importantly opportunity i mean it sounds
like if you got rid of the
authoritarianism these people would just
thrive yeah do you know like north
koreans as a nation one of the highest
iqs in the world no one the way they
build these nukes and you north korea's
only country can bully buy them right
byron's been trying to reach out to kim
jong-un
anytime anywhere without putting any
concessions i want to meet you and talk
to you kim jong-un will not return his
course since february but but trump
yeah trump was tough guy kim jong-un
knew that he could not bully trump so
whatever he was sending the love letters
to trump right pleasing and bad and like
kim jong knows like i can bully you
whatever way i want to well i love it
when kim jong-un called uh trump a
daughtered
you know
your daughter a daughter
like searched the world
yeah yeah old fumbling certainly that
that worked for joe biden yeah but then
trump was like i would never call him
short and fat
wow that was our president
so but but how do you feel about you
know uh i'll tell you this there are a
lot of people who are in this country
don't like trump
and like clockwork they were all
extremely critical of trump for meeting
with kim jong-un and cross and and just
meeting him in general i looked at that
when trump crossed the dmz into north
korea with no security
i thought that was tremendous but what's
what's your thought
back then i was more like seeing black
and white like you don't just sit down
with the modern day hitler and then
treating him like modern like actual
leader of the country like north korean
people didn't choose kim jong-un to
represent us he's a dictator right so
the fact that trump was going there
without actually any concessions from
like kim jong-un was already lost he
didn't get anything back instead kim
jong un did a huge promotion at home
showing like look at me now even though
america is backing me so if there's any
internal criteria that would happen they
don't want to go after a guy that is
accepting as a legitimate leader so
internally it was so bad however now
like in a way
biting is worse right like i mean trump
at least brought a highlight to the
issue and tried to serve something about
it like by then recently they reviewed
their policy towards north korea
which is going to be exactly what obama
did strategic patience which is a
strategically you do not think just
waiting and kim jong-un moved uh take
the first positive move
so the if they ignore north korea like
this four or five years and eight years
later we don't know what north korea
ends up with nuclear like capability
yeah yeah i i certainly see what you're
saying with trump i was uh i was hopeful
that
you know trump without security
crossed into north korea and they could
have just snatched him up they had not
you know obviously
they wouldn't because there's you can't
take the american president but it felt
like at least this was some
normalization some yeah but but i
certainly see what you're saying i was
hoping that it was a first step towards
trust
and maybe some kind of normalized trade
maybe some kind of encouragement towards
you know look there's opportunity if you
if you change some of the your ways but
you know based on what what you've all
been saying about how china wants the
reform and they don't it really does
feel like this the the kim il family is
a bunch of despotic what's the what's
the megalomaniacs
who think they're god yeah they're so
paranoid and also the thing is i mean if
we are negotiating with norway for the
first time makes sense to
honor them make them feel comfortable
and trusted this guy's been playing the
same playbook for like not 70 something
years
they know what they know
what they want to
so in a way it just doesn't work anymore
like talking to north korea and then
just try to make them warm and come out
it's not gonna work it's gonna take way
more than to change north korea when
when you lived there did you ever
encounter south korean propaganda
in north korea
every single day
like i did not know south korea was
independent country they told us that
eurus is colonizing them it's a modern
day colonization and then how these
children get raped by your soldiers
and entirely like cartoons filled with
the most corrupt and then how entire
humanity want to come to north korea
yeah
entire humanity there's a song in north
dakota nothing to envy
it's a song because we have nothing done
we live in a socialist paradise you
literally have nothing
you know um
when i interviewed these these uh new
zealanders who rode their motorcycles
through new zealand i'm through north
korea the one thing i did say was like
beautiful country
untainted
nature
no no no no trash no trash but that's
not true you think so right you don't
think so
look at just the why north korea
every year they have flooding
massive flooding
so we don't have it as electricity north
korea is very cold we are like 80
mountains the country
so people need to get us dominant to
burn cook food we live in like 16th
century time we go to river to bath we i
never seen a shower like never seen
anything we go to a few times a year we
go to river we take a bath and that's it
so we have to get a chop the woods to
fire start a fire so people go into the
mountains and cut down entire trees and
the big trees china took it china took
it and then the coal mining so
china owned north korea now
they lent these like mines coal mines
gold mines for 100 years at least 200
years late so they're digging digging
digging pollution and the nuclear the
debris they're doing so much test that
now people north korea got deformed in
their like
dna changes so so much flooding i mean
they're i'm sure they've gone to a part
where there are trees there yeah but
when normal people live we don't get the
trees we don't get nature
i'm so shocked when i was here today
seeing all these trees like so many
trees
oh you're in chicago now too yeah yeah i
think a lot of people uh might not know
this i didn't even i grew up in chicago
when you fly in
chicago is like a forest because every
city street has just a tree in front of
every house yeah right you go to new
york and it's there's trees but it's a
big concrete block and la's the same way
yeah trees everywhere yeah that's that's
that really is something truly amazing
about chicago that i i should definitely
give a credit for
a lot of cities but to have every city
street with trees lining every house it
really is it really is fantastic yeah so
i i i'm pretty sure
the people that i interviewed
they said that they chose their route
but i'm sure it was just that it was an
acceptable route in the first place of
course because if they went through
bad areas
it was interesting he said
they told me that
a lot of people criticized north korea
for their potemkin villages when when
someone comes in to interview they bring
them and they show them this wonderful
supermarket they say look at all the
glorious bounty
and we in the u.s we say they're putting
on a show to make it seem like they're
successful
what this uh this new zealander told me
was no no they're just dressing up like
like when you have your friends over you
wear your sunday's best you're not
trying to lie to them you're trying to
be presentable right
that was their perspective on it my
perspective is they're trying to trick
you into thinking that people aren't
suffering and dying in the streets
soviet union did that worked on a lot of
u.s officials bernie sanders
who who was it who said that uh they
they came to the u.s and said if if my
people saw what
you know uh we've done to them because
he was like at a supermarket he was a
cuban guy was it a cuban yeah there's a
cuban guy who said you know he was at an
aldi
right so it's not even like it's not
like a whole foods you got an aldi isn't
that not an american chain it's german
isn't it german yeah
so
like he was yeah he was just saying like
he was standing in an aldi and then he
got too depressed and had to leave
because he was like they've destroyed
our people like they've destroyed our
country like yeah i thought there was a
russian guy who said that you know if if
the people saw
the you know the variety or whatever
of the americans there would be a
revolution overnight or something like
that that sounds familiar i can't place
it though i do think there's something
silly about having like 80 different
kinds of peanut butter
but i suppose i'll take 80 kinds of
peanut butter over no peanut butter at
all the market will decide
all one kind of peanut butter yeah right
right right
kim jong-un brand peanut butter
different flavors here's one with the
red label there's one with the yellow
label
yeah the joke is that in um
in communist countries you wait in a red
line in capitalist countries the bride
line forms for you or something like
that yeah the bride is in the line
waiting for you all just on the shelf
and everything like that i mean we we
have our problems though
i think that
if you go back to the early 1900s the
rise of the communists and the fascist
factions in in in europe
and uh you know more so towards world
war ii
the communists get defeated in europe by
the fascists the fascists get defeated
by the allies and the soviet union but
then communism begins to flourish unless
we get the cold war for several decades
i think one of the challenges we face is
that
individual liberty
has weaknesses
we tolerate these authoritarians these
communists and they exploit yeah and so
sure we had a cold war
we won the cold war but i don't think
the cold war is actually over sure the
soviet union collapsed because their
ideology doesn't work their plans make
no sense they have to kill people to
support it but so long as there are
zealots who are willing to lie cheat and
steal to what they want
we we potentially walk the path towards
that corruption as well certainly you
know countries became the way they were
it's going to require everybody to be
constantly paying attention and fighting
back otherwise we we end up you know
like those countries
well ideological subversion is a huge
part of
communist tactics uh
chinese communist party does it all the
time they learn from the soviet union
and enhance things there's hardly a
u.s official who hasn't at some point
been offered a trip to china
or
money chinese money gets into all kinds
of places
and
and that's just we're talking about the
chinese communist party
the reality is that there are many
different factions to this broad concept
of communism
it's really a post-modern thing because
it does it kind of
defies
being pinned down to a definition
so
i mean like you you i've spoken to
people who are declared communists who
are like oh i hate what's happening
in china that's awful they don't see the
connections between themselves i do
think there's some kind of blindness
in the u.s about ideology on the left
where there's this kind of idea that
like there's no such thing as left
authoritarianism
where like we just pretend not to see it
or like the official media or whatever
pretend that there's no such thing as
left authoritarianism
you know
it's it's like a weird thing and it it
bleeds into like it happened with antifa
where people were like oh it's it's not
it's an idea not an organization but
then it also bleeds into like the china
stuff where you have people who are just
like well no china's not authoritarian
you know yeah well importantly like you
had the trump administration
particularly pompeo bringing up ideology
this is an ideological struggle with
china that is something that the binding
administration is incapable of
discussing it can only can be competing
powers but the ideology which is
critical to this is completely off the
table i think one of the
most clever things pulled off by the
communist or marxist or authoritarian
left is that they call themselves
libertarian left and we see this
expressed in memes
so there's the political compass memes
which i'm sure you you've seen the
political cause
yeah are you familiar with the political
compass it's it's it's a square and
there's four quadrants and then you have
the top left which is authoritarian the
top right which is authoritarian and the
bottom you know you have left and right
that are libertarian
so the libertarian writes easily
definable they're free market
capitalists
you know they're like you can sell
whatever you want to whoever you want as
long as you agree to it buyer beware
uh caveat emptor i think it's that's how
you say it and then you have the
authoritarian right which tends to be
ideologically driven command economies
ultra traditionalist and then you're the
authoritarian left which is the tankies
the soviet union etc but whenever you
look at the memes about the libertarian
left it's antifa
and it's wokeness to authoritarian
ideologies so these people i think they
do it on purpose it's very clever
you tell someone that if you want to be
the freedom loving libertarian leftist
the good guys you have to beat people
you have to start fires and believe in
our you know our cult ideology
in reality
if you look at the core of a libertarian
system with cooperative economics
it is small tribes it is small farms
working together it is
that's it you don't force anyone to do
anything you don't beat them in a
submission you don't demand they adhere
to an ideology
but if if our if our jokes if our whole
perspective in society is that
freedom loving leftists are the people
burning down buildings and
and canceling people and threatening
them and destroying their lives
there literally is no libertarian left
in the united states
so then what's the opposition what you
know what what opposes the
authoritarians
not the right the right of the bad guys
well that leaves you with only the right
because there is no opposition from the
left they have abandoned their
principles they are trying to fit in
they're trying to look good wokeness is
nothing if not the appearance of looking
compassionate and friendly it's nothing
if not the appearance of saying oh we'll
save you we'll bring in all these
immigrants and do all this stuff it
sounds great so there's no pushback on
it and there absolutely should be it's
put us in this position yeah it's it's
the tricky thing about marxism or
communism whatever you want to call this
ideology is that it really takes
advantage of the fact that i think most
people are good people they want to help
people they would like to see the world
be a more equal better place yeah but
marx presented this extremely simplistic
view of all of human society there are
only the oppressors and the oppressed
anything you do as an individual
doesn't matter you are either in the
oppressed or the oppressors to create a
better world
obviously you need to get rid of the
oppressors
they're not going to want to be
kicked out therefore
you have to kick them out yeah you know
we need we need
critical conservative theories all the
conservatives here you go
critical theory was you know the marxist
uh rooted very much in the marks
ideology of oppressors and depressed
based on class
i was actually just reading some good
old critical race theory to better
understand what they're talking about
and kimberly crenshaw wrote that
they they coined the phrase critical
race theory on purpose so that people
understood it came from the marxist
framework of critical theory but
critical theory uh and marxism didn't
understand american racism
so they needed to take his philosophy of
oppressed and oppressor and apply it to
racial politics united states
so we'll do the same thing now and we'll
create critical political theory and it
states that if you are a liberal you're
an oppressor and if you're a
conservative you're oppressed there you
go guys that one's free feel free to
claim that you're now victims yes there
you go the problem is it won't work
because the whole point
of marxism is to create struggle
and it divides people into different
groups makes them struggle and those
groups divide up into more groups and
they fight and fight et cetera et cetera
intersectionality i don't think it can
be solved by
people fighting each other right people
need to develop compassion
and and
because you know if you if any time
you're like arguing with people on the
internet is a nightmare and no one
should ever do it
i speak from experience pretty much uh
but when you're when you're actually
face to face with someone it
it comes down to basically like you know
somebody feels like they're being
attacked even if you are completely
wrong if you feel like you're being
attacked
you will either respond in three ways
fight flight or paralysis
and so if somebody feels like they're
being attacked that's what's going to
happen
you have to
make connections with people based on
like our common humanity because that is
the anticipation of marxism that we have
we have a shared common humanity there
are objective truths
it seems like the the the you know the
philosophy of marxism is just to
a tactic for destroying a system to
steal to steal power you know i made the
point the other day like a lot of people
say oh communism has never worked
that's not true communism has worked
everywhere it's been tried because the
point of communism is to create death
and destruction
it's designed to destroy a society yeah
they just pretend it's about helping you
and making the world a better place but
it's actually about how can i empower
myself and i i experienced this with
occupy wall street the activists
literally said
you know they would say we want to flip
the pyramid over
now to the untrained flipping the
pyramid over implies the working class
will now be on top
and the capital will be forced to be on
the bottom
what it really means is what i asked if
you flip a pyramid over the bricks
crumble into a disheveled pile
with only one of those bricks in the
working class sitting on top and there
and they're like and that'll be us and
where will the gua would live
in the bellies of uh of the people they
possess
so this is the social justice stuff is
very much a trojan horse which is
probably something that you you noticed
young me when you were at columbia was
that this guise of compassion and
kindness how did they couch it to you
when you were first learning about
social justice at your school did they
present as something highly positive or
did they force you to do this stuff
it wasn't just so i remember at the
orientation right and then she was like
instructor came so who likes like uh
jane austen i was like yeah me right
right yeah and because i didn't have
love i love like reading about romance
books and then like
do you know this or colonial mindset
biggest racist wow so even when you
think you don't know you're just reading
a classic you're being subconsciously
brainwashed by this white supremacist
so this is how you gotta be aware how
you can get very much every day
and like wow
did you speak up and say hey actually
i'm from north korea and uh
i did it so before the clock in
the class where there's like a western
civilization museum art in colombia you
have to take in a core curriculum
and then professor who has a problem
studying western civilization like the
music
and everybody like using their hands
and they said because of this white man
killed our minority and silenced women
we have to now study this bad
you know better than the mozart spigots
wow
i'm like they were talented you know
like this is musicians so like that
critically steering every single thing
they find a connection somehow
it's so smart they're so so creative to
look at the problem that way isn't it
it's oppressed or oppressor mozart
oppressor binary yeah they're now saying
beethoven was black though it was not
he wasn't
but they're actually now arguing that
because of white supremacy beethoven
couldn't actually be marketed as a black
man so they had to change his race
no joke wow there they uh there was this
big thing where they started claiming
that a black man invented the light bulb
and that thomas edison you know just
took credit for it but thomas edison was
not a cool dude don't get me wrong
but i think the actual story was that a
black man who worked for thomas edison
uh developed a special special filament
yeah
but but historical revisionism is very
very important right they need to get to
the point where they can tell us that
there is this individual who has got
and that you have to believe it or else
they need to get to the point where
people can't defend themselves will stop
resisting and will just give up so every
day that people challenge the system and
say no is a bad day for this this
machine but i i also will say
at least for now
i don't think there is a grand architect
or conspiracy or group that are trying
to make it happen i think
you could argue there's a conspiracy in
the sense that a bunch of people who
have a worldview rooted in this don't
realize they're destroying everything
around them some people for sure know
they're lying cheating and stealing but
it feels like domino's falling over you
know joe biden doesn't seem to be all
with it but he hears what people saying
critical race theory is good he goes
okay mark millie the general he has no
idea what he's talking about he goes i
just want to understand white rage and
it's like bro that's insane you're in
you're believing garbage
more and more people believe it it
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy
yeah i think this is where the beautiful
language stuff comes in because
if you you know people call people
useful idiots kind of but it's kind of
more like most of them are well-meaning
innocence i've heard that term where
like really they're just
you know they they want to be better
people like you were saying chris and
they want to but like the beautiful
language really
just it kind of pulls the wool over the
eyes of a lot of people and it's on
purpose you see this in every communist
society
where i mean in china they just came out
with a white paper the communist party
about uh you know how how the communist
party in china has led human rights for
a hundred years
they've been the leader of human rights
uh you know because we've you know like
this is the time where like they killed
80 million people yeah but they're like
yeah no we've definitely you know they
redefine human rights they say you know
we talk about the universal universality
of human rights within the context of
each country so they're already saying
human rights are universal but we're
going to change what this means for
human rights and then they go we believe
that human rights are subsistence
development
and contentment
and therefore these are like the metrics
that we're using to say that we've you
know we've lifted so many million people
out of poverty you know we are the
leader in huma in human rights but it's
even absurd even if you use that
standard because they killed and starved
and
like 80 million people so but like
they're able to kind of take this term
that sounds great human rights that
everybody's like these are universal you
know the u.n says human rights are
universal and then they kind of can come
and like twist that
to mean something else and then make
themselves look good that is so
interesting to me that they call it the
beautiful language because this is
exactly what they're doing in the u.s
they're changing these terms and this is
why i brought up the topic of
definitions yesterday when you're going
into a debate you lay out your
definitions before you even get started
nothing proceeds until you know exactly
where everyone stands and where
everything is lined up and this is why
they won't define this is why
post-modernism is so dangerous it's
because they defy definition it's it's
one of their stronger points it's
basically what makes post-modernism what
it is it gives them this ability to kind
of change the way you perceive the world
and when you're arguing with them oh
well i didn't mean that that doesn't
mean that anymore that used to mean that
it's evolved critical race theory yes
christopher ruffo goes on joy reid's
show on msnbc and says
critical race theory is rooted in
marxism and she goes no it isn't and
he's like uh intersectionality is rooted
in critical race there no it's not
this author is a critical racers no she
isn't and all everything he said was
true and verifiable
but they changed the definitions
she goes
robin d'angelo isn't a critical race
theorist she's a critical white studies
author
of course critical white studies is a
component of critical race theory they
just try and make it as confusing as
possible so you can never criticize them
they cement it's all semantics i mean it
is like orwell
wrote in 1984 it's like you lose a
language to describe objective reality
and it drives you crazy
right and that's
i mean like that's really destructive i
think this is when i'm shocked something
i think these are
defectors in the beginning having a hard
time because in north korea
words like it doesn't mean anything
i mean like right like
no words
words mean nothing is in tv like say oh
maybe leaving the social paradise blah
blah i mean there's never a bad news
right so everything that you study in
school is not really relevant to your
actual life when i came here
i was so shocked how seriously the words
meant to people
and
i don't know it's so insane i don't know
how they did that in north korea
i mean it's it's kind of the way that a
communist
is it like the regime like destroys
society in a certain sense because you
destroy the meaning of language so like
everybody's a liar yeah you have to be a
liar all the time yeah for your survival
and then there's nothing right well uh
you made a stargate reference earlier
yes i did sg-1 though well i guess so in
the movie
they go to this this other planet
through the stardust
portal and when they try and write on
the ground the the the slaves there
freak out like writing is forbidden what
are you doing
and they're like we're trying to convey
an idea to you through it's like you
can't do that
and it's because when people have the
ability to communicate you know they
become dangerous they share ideas they
become they become more knowledgeable
they start to understand the collective
computational power of a large group of
people is a lot so to keep people
oppressed you must limit their ability
to understand reality and share those
ideas
well this is why i think the united
states of america has always been the
greatest enemy to communism
you know it states we hold these truths
to be self-evident that all men are
created equal that there is this
uh
i mean they called it like nature or the
creator that gives people inalienable
rights this is different from
most other countries that you you don't
have freedom of speech or freedom of
religion because the government grants
you that
you have it because you're human you
have this because some something beyond
human understanding has made it an
innate part of your existence
and that creates an objective reality
that
is the opposite of communism like chile
was talking about with human rights in
china what they're saying is we have our
definition of human rights you have your
definitions of human rights don't
enforce your values don't push your
values on us
and but and then you get lost in like
all these word games but if you just
zoom out and like what the chinese
communist party is doing to the uyghurs
is evil right what it's doing to falun
gong is evil what's doing to all the
chinese people is evil that is objective
truth
the one thing that greatly benefits
china in the international conflict
where we're trying to convince people
who's right who's wrong is the narrative
of black lives matter in the united
states about some grand
institutionalized racism where they come
out and say look what you're doing to
these minorities and it's all
exaggerated or extreme
or
at the very least they hyper focus on
some stories that make it seem like the
whole of the country is racist or broken
i mean that's what chinese propaganda
has been doing about the us for years um
every day there's a 30-minute chinese
news show that plays
on every channel right and like it's
always whenever they talk about america
it's always about how dangerous and
violent and racist and whatever how bad
it is and so this stuff about
critical race theory is kind of just
like
it's exactly the same thing and they are
so happy the chinese communist party
like loves this they use it all the time
like they can just say oh well you can't
criticize us for wuhan
the live league or the coronavirus i
mean they won't admit it's a lobby but
you know you say that it's racist
there was a incident that happened in
the u.n last week where canada was about
to bring up that there should be an
investigation into the uyghur genocide
and the chinese representative stood up
and was like
preemptively said actually there needs
to be an investigation to canada
for what happened to the indigenous
children
you know like like he just like right
before the canadian official was going
to say something just came up in a
classic communist party move yeah yeah
so yeah they love that you know you know
you know it's funny there's a it's like
a joke idea um
what if we are actually in north korea
not like literally the physical space
like what if people in america are the
ones who think they're so smart and
think they know the world but
it's all propaganda it's all
manipulation it's all controlled and
then actually in these other countries
they have spaceships and they have you
know 100 years more advanced technology
the idea is that for a lot of people you
just believe what the tv tells you is
believe the newspapers tell you i
suppose the difference in the united
states we have these kinds of
conversations that challenge our own
understanding of the world we also have
freedom of movement so we can go to
these other countries or meet people in
these countries you can't though
you can go to a lot of countries but
there are some countries you can't go to
american passport will not get you in
not north korea
i have to take your word for it and you
might be cia yeah
see
that proves it i know yes
but there are a lot of countries you
can't get into no i i i think it's a
funny idea but uh you
the fact that you can even mention this
idea that our government does lie to us
of course they lie to us there's
classified information they have to lie
in some circumstances but they lie when
they shouldn't and there's a lot of
people who are corrupt but then our
media lies to us all the time as well i
do think it's funny when we talk about
the things china is doing
and
you know you mentioned that china's got
this program where they say all these
things about the united states
we got the same thing sort of right
we've got these corporate
american deep state whatever media that
just say whatever the establishment
wants them to say granted
we also have the internet with some
free speech still available to the rest
of us but more so than these many many
of these other countries
i mean the great thing for china is that
the american corporate media is saying
the same thing as the chinese
propagandists
especially during the entire corona
virus
the solid they did for china oh yeah and
youtube's saying you can't uh speak out
against the world health organization
what they say is law
don't say anything that contradicts them
well even worse this is something we
covered recently like a lot of these
medical journals early on that we're
saying
uh
you know it's lively hypothesis complete
conspiracy theory
uh not only were they
quoting scientists like doctor peter
dadzik who was working with the wuhan
institute of virology right
china is giving money to some of the
biggest medical journals in the world
lancet and springer nature right yeah
springer nature and
elsevier who is the parent
company of lancet they get a lot of
money from china to publish open access
journals so somebody estimated that
springer nature's deal with china is
worth like 10 million a year
you want you want to know i i think it's
much worse than anybody realizes
let me explain to you guys how easy it
is to control the american narrative
especially with something like youtube
youtube is one of the greatest vehicles
for political propaganda ever created
let's say you're china you want the
american public to believe your lies and
your propaganda
it's simple
take a large portion of your money
and then
buy ads
on the youtube channels
that say the things that uh you like
it's that simple what ends up happening
is youtube sees that uh oh advertisers
really love these particular uh
youtubers
they generate a ton of ad revenue prop
them up boost them in the algorithm
they get prominent uh positioning they
get more and more views they become
wealthy and successful they hire people
and expand their companies
it's that simple there's no way to track
it unless google was audited and forced
to reveal where the money is coming
through but it's very it this works in
any capacity
any individual can run any video as an
ad and anybody can buy an advertisement
and choose to run it on a specific
channel
so if you find somebody who's producing
a show called like
china you know the youtube channel
called why china is right and every day
they do an hour video where as an
american they're like this lies in
propaganda china is great
some political actor
might not be able to physically fund
that without an ad appearing youtube
will say this is a chinese sponsored but
the chinese government can put money
into a company which then advertises
sneakers
and they say we want to run all of these
ads for sneakers on this channel unless
china is right on this china is right
channel and you think this china is
right channel would make a lot of money
it makes a lot of money because they're
giving the money to the creator and to
google google doesn't have notes
well so think about it right
if you guys have a youtube channel the
us government could be secretly putting
money into google and you would never
know as an individual
you would not know
because google just says hey here's how
much money you made in ads and you have
no idea where the ads came from or what
the ads are for
i thought people they mentioned to me
like oh i got a bloomberg ad on your
video once this is back during the
election or whatever primaries and i'm
like good i rag on the guy all the time
so if he's paying me to rag on him it's
understandable that he wants to try and
counter that narrative but i don't think
you guys buy it right i think my
audience is smart enough to realize the
dude's full of it he's buying political
ads and i'll take his money
but what if what if it's more insidious
than that what if it's a company for air
conditioners
just
every ad spot that you have so this
there's ad inventory
your video could be a certain amount of
minutes maybe it's 15 minutes and a
youtube ad can appear every certain
amount of minutes in the algorithmically
they they restrict how many ads can
appear
not every video sells every possible ad
space
but what if you were uh
china
you saw a youtuber who was constantly
saying things good about you you could
indirectly
make sure every single available ad on
that channel was paid for and that
youtuber is now making tons of money
successful
and driven to produce more of the
content they're doing because it works
china's doing it simpler they're just
they're just directly paying yeah some
youtubers and i don't think those
youtubers have like a state sponsored no
right they're a bunch of like like white
pro china youtubers suddenly who are
going to xinjiang and walking around
saying there's no genocide here
wow look at this cotton field where's
the genocide there was uh
this really creepy moment where
china was uh
asking people to upload a video to their
youtube channels where it was a guy
complaining about a falun gong show in
new york city they were like i think it
was falun gong i'm not sure
it was some like theater show
and he was like
this is wrong and creepy why is this
religious organization being allowed to
put on this show and you you'd get an
email and they were like we'll give you
200 to upload this to your channel right
now and oh yeah i heard about this yeah
yeah that's super weird
yeah i think it's against the rules
but maybe not maybe not do you guys feel
like this is capitalism defeating itself
like the fact that people are being able
to monetize this money that's available
to weaponize
information against the way that the
west has become powerful that's kind of
what i've been thinking
this might be kind of a tangential
answer to that question but i think
like i don't believe in capitalism i
think that's a that's a marxist kind of
construct
you have communism or you have
capitalism and that's not really true
it's like you have
freedom to engage in the economy it's
it's not it was freedom yeah capitalism
existed as like the normal normal human
mode of trade and economics and then
marx kind of gave a name to it right
right right so it's just enterprise
yeah and while also ignoring that you
know there were other systems like
mercantilism or subsistence farming
it just blames all the problems in
history
that guy was nuts
he was a dude i hear he smelled bad too
racist
he should be canceled for his racism he
actually was kind of racist right
yeah
all right well uh uh we should take
super chats if you haven't already give
us a like that like button subscribe to
the channel and share the show if you
think these conversations are important
we definitely have more like it and now
there's a lot of questions because this
is like one of the more serious you know
shows that we've done yeah
all right
ardwick says it's about time tim gets a
real korean on his show joking joking
love you both hi yummy
all right
i think they want more stargate i think
so yeah i've been watching a lot of sg1
i love that show yeah me too yeah big
fan
oh yeah you guys you've all been
watching it yeah really yeah i i missed
it when it was on so i've been going
through it on netflix
now i'm like on the sixth season
is the best
toilet for me
okay i i think i'm on season three but i
think i started with season two so i
need to like stop and go back and make
sure i watch but having a blast all
right mark
giadetti said
he says
janmi is such an inspiring human being
tim it's surprising it uh it took this
long to have her as a guest
well you know we have to do it thank you
garhen says chris and shelley love your
show can you talk about your uyghur
teacher who escaped interview
and then they said yanmey is the hottest
korean in america sorry tim
i think he's talking about the guy we
interviewed who he was that he tried to
start at kindergarten oh the him yeah
and he tried to start a kindergarten and
was put in prison for it because he
wanted to teach the uyghur language in
this kindergarten and the most
interesting thing i think that came out
of our conversation he was also raped
when he was put in this like prison
standard for everyone it's just he said
it's just a matter of how much
he was like a little he was raped only
once or twice i think that was kind of
how he put it but like he talked about
how
you know even growing up as a uyghur in
china he had this idea that
like it was kind of a misunderstanding
that if the chinese communist party just
really understood what was happening
with the uyghurs like on the ground then
there wouldn't be so much repression you
know like he just kind of thought it was
a misunderstanding and this is something
we've heard from multiple
chinese dissidents or people have been
imprisoned for their beliefs or whatever
that like they thought it was just like
because they grew up in this environment
where they're taught like even if you
try to resist the brainwashing if you're
a dissident you're a pretty stubborn
person right you're a pretty stubborn
opinionated person but even
people who were like able to dissent
from an authoritarian system they had
that part of them that was kind of a
little bit in disbelief that it would
actually get so bad like he didn't think
he was going to go to prison for
starting a kindergarten right yeah
like those the recent student protests
they had a legitimate complaint about
the government taking private schools
and blending them with vocational
schools kind of watering down
their degrees
they protested i don't think they knew
that they were protesting on the
anniversary of june 4th the tiananmen
square
because they didn't know they were
problems
yeah and yeah so i'm sure to them it's
it's i think what always happens is it's
like oh this is an obviously reasonable
thing obviously the party is reasonable
nope it's not
and actually this was something this was
a really good point for understanding
china that um
another huge chinese youtuber lao y86
yeah uh sea milk
mentioned and i thought this was really
really clever when people like the
communist party says like you know
people in china huge approval ratings of
the communist party and now there's all
the propaganda to you know whatever but
i think but he said part of it is
essentially true that when people think
of the communist party and the communist
party they like they think of the big
far away central government the main
ideas but if you ask people about their
local years the communist party having a
direct impact on their lives that's when
they're like oh we hate the local
officials
it's separated in their minds yeah all
right patty b says i used to think agent
smith was a bad guy but watching china
uncensored changed my mind
thanks china uncensored for your work
exposing the ccp it's especially
important for my country australia
graphene for life yes ian is not here
today though
thank you
bub savvy says repeat after me i trust
the government they will not take my
wealth but the wealth of those i choose
wealth that once distributed will
reflect on society my virtues i repeat
with confidence i trust the government
indeed yeah i don't know about that one
that'll work
all right what is this what is this um
el rojo grande says hey tim psa just
released a limited edition ar-15 lower
in response to biden's comments on
defense from a tyrannical government the
tyranny 15 safety selection has freedom
f-15 and nukes engraving very cool yeah
joe biden
uh i made the joke on twitter that i'm
sure uh king king george iii said you
you you doth think that i would succeed
in battle against the crown because they
don't really talk that way i know
you would need cavalry and frigates
yep this idea that joe biden basically
said
if we're a repressive government
don't even bother that's what it sounded
like you were saying it's the craziest
thing
yeah it was also a reference a quote
from thomas jefferson which was which is
funny for him to uh kind of disparage
okay let's see we got
tom holland says hey tim and crew 25
year old brain cancer survivor can be
secretary whatever you guys need minimal
pay i love what you guys do
feel free to uh send an email over to
jobs at timcast.com yeah
all right jay vance 131 says i love you
me park please let her know that all of
us in america support her and we will
always protect her she is an amazing and
very brave woman that is true thank you
chuck norris gun club says send her to
congress
yes yeah have you have you testified to
congress before any issues i think
that'd be very important for how do we
make that happen
um i don't know people should find the
appropriate republican who has the uh
gall to challenge woke-ism and wokeness
and bring on someone who's had
experience josh hawley would that be
scientists massey
rubio
yeah maybe maybe i think holly would do
it i think cruz cruz ted cruz he wrote a
letter about this and introduced a bill
to ban critical race theory so ted cruz
are you listening yeah definitely should
have young me park testify about what
what these communists do and that lady
from virginia
the lady from virginia yeah the lady who
escaped mao is china oh oh oh i'm like i
thought you were referring to a
politician no no no no not from virginia
no way
hey loudoun county is doing all right i
know yeah that's where that lady was
final
why uh final exer
yikes her i'm not sure he says uh her
story is literally heartbreaking i
always knew north korea was bad but this
is crazy
yeah the story about no love like that
is dark sad wow
fab joe says most of us know tim's
opinion about trump crossing the dmz but
janmi has a contrasting opinion i'd love
for you to have a discussion about it uh
well that super chat was actually before
i think we did bring it up yeah because
for me it was kind of like
trump took a big risk doing it but i but
i certainly think he ended up not
getting
much from it
rockslide says i had to donate today to
say that you are a hero yummy hearing
your story shook me to my core and in
this world not much does that anymore
you are a glowing reminder why this
fight is so important amen oh thank you
that's the nicest thing i ever heard i
mean i became vegan after fox news thing
and they were like actually my personal
friends reaching out to me
i'm concerned about you why are you
doing this why are you being like oh why
are being used by like hannity sean
hannity he said he's a liar he's a
propagandist why did you have to share
their own fox news and i was like they
were the only one who was interested in
listening to me
if new york times calls me i'm going to
interview with them and share my views
and they're like okay
but the new york times didn't call you
know but they're communists so yeah not
literally but there are this this
ideological element taking over these
these industries but it was interesting
when i was criticizing trump
new york times loved me of course they
did yeah yeah so whenever i defeat their
narrative they use me so they are the
ones actually using you
and it's like yeah
i uh uh
mark robert shaw says kim is a goat
why is star great all of a sudden
becoming relevant
so i used to i used to quote star trek
all the time and people were like tim
you got to watch stargate sg1 so i was
like i started watching it and i watch
it like couple episodes every day
now all of a sudden it's not star trek
anymore stargate it's a good show though
fantastic show it is really cool a
really cool show
except for the weird full-frontal nudity
in the pilots oh boy what was there yeah
it was i think they were forgotten i
didn't see the pilot it was because it
was on show time yeah i was gonna be on
showtime so they were like oh this is
showtime like a nude richard dean
anderson or something no no no no no
nude women oh of course yeah they know
their audience yeah well then yeah yeah
yeah
richard anderson if you're watching
he's a great character though um o'neil
was fantastic he's fantastic very
different from the movie all right
michael brogan says my question is for
yomi i noticed that you couldn't laugh
at the absurdities of the north korean
regime the concept is foreign to us in
americans how long did it take you to
get to that point and is it a normal
reaction now
to
be
not shocked by like the reason like to
laugh at what they do and what they
represent i suppose
the other day i was hearing this meme
right in north korea killing yourself is
uh is a crime so if someone try to kill
yourself they are going to execute you
oh my gosh
i saw that one you're gonna kill
yourself anyway
that that that is so dark very dark
but it's it's it's like obvious why it's
funny it's it's a representation of how
horribly mismanaged and nonsensical this
is the third yeah and they do not allow
any disobedience even killing yourself
is not up to you right it's up to me as
a state you do not even have that right
so that's the thing like in america
people are saying oh my god we have so
much problem we have homeless people
so do you know what happens if you
become homeless in north korea you send
a prison care so being a homeless is a
privilege guys like you have that much
freedom
and interesting i couldn't believe like
these people just they choose be
homeless and that's their freedom
and yeah in order to we don't even have
that freedom there is no gratitude in
the u.s yeah freedom to fail yeah yeah
no
okay
matthew lunsford says thanks for
fighting against critical race theory
i'm not a colonizer and my wife isn't
depressed my children shouldn't be
taught otherwise
i definitely think one of the biggest uh
weaknesses of critical race theory and
the critic and these these identitarians
is mixed race people yeah telling
telling a white person they're an
oppressor and they're evil it's like
they're literally married to a person of
a different race or or you know could be
the man or the woman and then all of a
sudden they just say oh well you're
fetishizing the other person and it's
like you are seriously insulting love
like few people who care about each
other and love each other and what does
that mean to their kids who can't split
their dna apart and not be a product of
your psychotic
ideology
yeah you can take personal uh issue with
them understandably yeah
bonker says nobody really owns land in
the us either miss a property tax
payment and see what happens the only
difference is we can hand our property
uh we we can hand our property in the
tax department with it down to our
family
but can you do that in china like the
lease you buy give to a family member
like if you die or something i mean it's
good for 70 years
okay really so
theoretically yes so it's still very
different though yeah but like most
people don't actually own even a lease
to a land because most property in china
is apartments
so you know you can own the apartment
but you can't own any of the land
associated with it
interesting
says i'm a korean canadian from south
i'm quite sure i know more about north
korean history than most north koreans
things always start with a bait the most
prominent one being land redistribution
oh definitely and i think that's true
though
does it do do you think that's true that
south koreans probably know more about
north korea than north koreans oh you
know more about north korea
no students know about themselves i mean
they say i told you
we don't even know like we are isolated
yeah so when people say like at columbia
they're like i'm so oppressed right like
do you know actually when you're
oppressed you don't know you're
oppressed
i believe it was harriet tubman who said
i freed many slaves i would have freed
many more if only they knew they were
slaves wow exactly
powerful stuff
grant says ask you on me about north
korean education and how they combine
math with indoctrination
so yeah that's the thing everything but
other than that the most important
subject you have to learn is the the you
know the kim's revolution history like
what kind of miracles they do you know
how much they love their people if if if
uh uh he's a god if kim sung was a god
then what's what's the story of the
creation of north korea like do they
believe he just manifested it or do they
believe was a revolution no there was a
rainbow and singing in the sky the
universe chose the light came out you
know from the mountains
[Laughter]
but but they do believe it came from the
mountain right that was it the back door
back to mountain and then this is a
universe chosen it's not us so yeah but
then so then he gave us his son yeah but
then what's kim jong-un so
they lost a little bit
but they said like kim jong-un is more
like the father the first grandfather he
came back to serve the people
so they said he actually did plastic
surgery to look like his grandfather he
didn't do it yeah he acted like
grandfather so to remind people like
that's how much the dear leader loves
you
yeah i have a feeling that there's like
at some point you got a bunch of these
like north korean communist party
members and they're like sitting there
like kind of just half glazed over uh
let's just say uh kim il-sung came back
i don't know whatever they'll believe it
they will believe yeah i guess but you
literally get executed the one of the
execution kim jong-un somebody better
sleep during the meeting
and that afternoon he just got executed
he's the top type of fisher in the
country wow don't they want to leave
no
because they know
they are loyalties right these this
official guys have a hundreds concubines
there is no such a concept in north
korea rape or sexual harassment nobody
can persecute for that so if officials
walking on the street i want that girl
bring her
nobody persecute them
it's a horrifying place so yeah for
these guys
it's their dream like kim jong-un has a
pleasure squad they go around the
country
every village every school they bring
these girls train them
and then make them pleasure squad but
not only for kim's
everybody else all these tabulis men
so they have these lost parties while
they're putting communist motors to us
there there are a lot of stories that
certainly certainly make me understand
why people are interventionalists yeah
interventionist is that the right word
yeah
i just think like when i hear these
stories it's like everyone in america
lives a life of privileged parents yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and we need to know these things
we need to know how good we have it yes
i think it's one of the problems we're
facing a lot of younger people
millennial uh gen z jen alpha
they think they have it bad yeah well i
always say this like when was the last
time you had to pay a bribe
in america
you can't that's so that is common in
the world in so many countries that's
like daily life yeah
not not in the us in the u.s people are
so scared of losing their jobs they
won't even stand up for themselves
not everybody but a lot of people are
like i can't take a bribe i'll get in
trouble
we have scruples it's a good thing
it worries me though because i think
we're losing it we're getting to that
point where bribes might actually matter
however though the woke ideology stuff
purity is more important than anything
so when you're terrified of getting
cancelled people won't cross
no
though some people end up with
multi-million dollar mansions i mean
that's right yeah that's true
your girlfriend's boyfriend says i'm a
big manly man and hearing the finer
details of yami's story made me cry and
unable to repeat to others why because
it was so harsh on a lighter note i want
to take her to dinner and see how much
she can eat now
oh i can eat i believe it oh yeah i
definitely get it
michael mckesson says tim your love your
video shooting the m82 brings a smile to
my face
yeah we went out with a barrett m82 do
you guys know what that is
um i imagine it's big yes it's very big
it is for hunting helicopters
yes
there's too many helicopters in this
country it's true yeah they become a
nuisance every so often and you gotta
call the numbers otherwise they keep
breeding and there's helicopters
everywhere but it's so cute when they're
feeding their young little babies
uh it really is for hunting helicopters
not literally not like anyone's actually
doing in the united states
it's just a very very large
well come on man why does anyone need
that kind of a gun i mean helicopters um
because
it's a
helicopters what do you mean
you never know you know bad helicopter
what if like a what if a burglar comes
to your house in a helicopter
an apache and you're like hey you know
we're supposed to uh we're allowed to
have that's a thing joe biden doesn't
want us to have it that's for sure but
we are
commander 232 says park i have much
respect for you and wish you the best i
was stationed in south korea in 2010
through 2011 when i was in the army and
all the korean people i met were so
welcoming and wanting to work with you
uh
and wanting to work with you and that
included north koreans i met at the dmz
interesting wow i was there i was seeing
south korea then how interesting oh wow
i went to uh the first time i ever went
it was with luke actually and we went to
a raccoon cafe have you ever did you
ever go to any of those
where you go inside and there's raccoons
everywhere and you can just pet them and
they're like you give them food it
sounds incredibly dangerous
it's like terrible we have a cat cafe
yeah those sheep baby lamb cafes yes and
there were dog cafes
but the dogs are so messy yeah they're
like barfing
and you're like i'm tr like they expect
you to sit down and like have food or
like have a drink like a boba or
something that's like there's just dogs
running around
it was fun though we went it was
definitely fun
okay mountain man chuck says random
question for yomi have you ever been to
a live performance of beethoven's ninth
symphony
no i haven't i would love to yeah yeah i
think
biggest appreciation that i have is that
for north korean people his story was
forgotten so i never knew i mean even
though god made you or the big bang
happened still we can like connect to
humanity longer yeah but in norway in
north korea you just never learned
anything before kim like our candidates
started to say when kim is born
everything before was erased for us
so i think i feel like this lineage now
with humanity but in nursing you just
don't have that so if they believe that
like rainbows and singing in the sky and
then from the mountains comes kim
il-sung who's everybody else who are the
americans like where do they come from
no they're you guys are so
my
friend my friend i took to south korea
my mom was first touching her because we
learned that you guys are cold-blooded
and you don't have internet you cannot
look up how americans look like like
school posters that's how they show
their huge nose green eyes what and
yankees and like cold blooded monsters
right they don't even have a heart huh
what was your mom's reaction when she
she's like oh my god you're a worm
[Laughter]
and she was like why would you touch
yours yeah
she always wanted to know if they were
actually cold blooded or not interesting
yeah
morgan near ten dollars for knowles the
first time ten dollars for lauren chen
ten dollars from all the second time ten
dollars for china uncensored ten dollars
for uber ian yeah ten for wonderful lids
ten for yami the bravest most wonderful
voice we have and ten dollars for
teaching about the horrors of communism
god bless thank you thank you very much
it is certainly horrifying
all right let's see
oh man there's some uh i think someone
super chatted in uh in korean i can't
read that one
all right let's see but we'll come down
to that we'll come back it jumps and you
get a big in influx of super chats
ken bosack says something something
bitcoin fixes this
yeah i mean we talk about crypto all the
time but i certainly think bitcoin does
in many ways in venezuela for instance
where they want to control and regulate
currency and control the people they can
share with bitcoin yeah of course in
north korea if you don't have a
smartphone the technology to actually
use this stuff
it's probably hard to actually um
you don't fix it
here's a question that's probably for me
but i'll i'll say it for uh we'll i'll
ask you on me brent chapel says what has
been your favorite anime so far and
which one do you want to watch next
anime yeah
japanese cartoons
so this is the thing because uh i came
out as like almost 17 years old
i i mean i did not know michael jackson
was right when his people said michael
jackson was the biggest who was that and
then when steve jobs died like i have no
clues to jose's so my culture thing is
so behind
so i actually never seen any anime it's
like um
when captain america had the book of all
the things he missed when he was yeah
and i was like i'm going to i'm going to
taste the lobster and like tomorrow i'm
going to eat shrimp i'm going to eat
this all the stuff to do yeah yeah well
when naomi said like she had never seen
a shower before i was thinking of like
demolition man
like oh he doesn't know what the three
seashells are right yeah he's not using
shells it's like that that's if you come
from north korea you have no idea the
shells yeah
all right
alternative jk90 says shout out to yon
me and china uncensored uh for what you
do best question for yon me shelly and
chris
what is your take on the south korean
president my mom believes he's secret he
secretly is siding with president xi and
the ccp thank you young me from a korean
oh thank you and i'm gonna let chris you
guys you guys does such a good job
covering about it uh well i wouldn't it
doesn't seem so secret to me
i mean
like uh
mundane
in his youth he was a a a leftist a kind
of a communist sympathizer so there are
a lot of people who think that he is
still basically that and the people that
are in power in south korea are
sympathize with north korea
would like to unify right with north
korea and
also are sympathetic towards china and
turning away from the u.s essentially we
did a few videos on china and censored
about that topic
interesting
so the idea of unification that he wants
is let's like come together and let's
vote
in south korea they're like 10 more
parties north korea one communist party
right so who gets more votes can i rule
the entire career
so yeah in korea you get like 90 90 of
the voting rate so they won't be exactly
go under kim jong-un you can vote
communism in yeah yeah yeah
you can't vote it out you know that you
gotta fight your way out that's what is
right yeah
all right yeah so zhang the great says
the use of the word capitalist and
subsequently capitalism were coined in
germany in the 1850s and ultimately
capitalized by a prominent german writer
karl marx the actual definition of our
system as capitalist is marxist thinking
it's not
that's right
1991 shadowheart says go out old lives
matter
tokra lives matter yes
[Laughter]
politically i know these references now
politically defiant says walter make it
spin also jason momoa will always be
ronin decks from atlantis well pegasus
galaxy
that's right
um
i hear good things about atlantis have
you watched target atlantis no i haven't
yet no i kind of think sg-1 you know
it's like
it's pretty good i got i got to watch
there's a lot to it though
a lot of people are mentioning they're
watching sgt oh my gosh great
andrew rohn says i'm getting anti-gun
ads on gun channels now i doubt that
these channels are getting the ad money
most likely youtube inserting propaganda
they're probably getting the ad money
they probably are um youtube allows ads
on on gun channels
maybe because of anti-gun propaganda so
long as the gun is in an appropriate
facility you can't have it in a bedroom
it's got to be in a gun range or a store
right you're fine and you also can't
take sponsorship from people who sell
guns
that's interesting we've uh covered gun
issues on our other show america
uncovered a few times and i think it's
always demonetized yeah that sounds
right
t-town says tim i'm not getting
notifications for you anymore they are
trying to bury you hashtag don't bury
tim that's right that's right they are
so you need to like this video subscribe
to this channel hit the notification
bell and even then it doesn't do
anything so i guess if you really like
the show you can share the show
and uh go to teamcast.com become a
member help support our work because
we're gonna be bringing on more
journalists and expanding our content
new website launching in just a few
weeks but i guess so long as you like
the show and you just come and watch it
of your own volition
youtube doesn't owe me promotion
youtube doesn't owe me notification
bells uh i guess technically if you
choose to get notified and you don't
they're kind of ripping you off so
set an alarm on your phone yeah for
monday through friday at 8pm yeah
nombot says sg1 is so relevant because
wokism equals goa old and season 4
episode 6 window opportunity best
episode ever i'm not there yet
i gotta really watch this show yeah it's
time to watch the show
all right we'll just do uh we'll do a
couple more here i'm lost
ai train i think it's a train or is it
al train
thank you for bringing yummy onto the
show i picked up her book recently and
it's one of the most heartbreaking
stories i've ever read what she went
through as hell and to come out of it
and be the person she is today is just
amazing she's a wonderful person yes
do you want to mention your book
yeah so
it's called in order to live yeah
that book ended when i began colombia
right before thank god imagine if i
would stay there there's going to be a
whole lot of chapter about it then maybe
it would not be published and reviewed
by in the mainstream so stuff that's the
kind of book that should be
required in schools you know
understanding other other cultures
understanding authoritarianism maybe in
florida you also have a youtube channel
oh yeah i do i have a channel that talks
about north korea cool yeah i want to
talk about the beauty standard of north
korea
so you know in north korea who's the
hottest guy
because everybody's so poor right so in
north korea have thing raised lines not
a beauty right being heavier if you are
bored symbol of status
so you gotta be chubby and bored
and you are very attractive there
there's uh so
we're gonna get maybe
we were having a laugh with michael
malus and we're talking about getting an
old-timey painting where we can like
take the eyes out and have the eyes
follow you and
michael said that we should he showed us
a picture a painting of kim jong-il
wearing a samurai outfit and riding a
tiger oh have you ever seen that
painting before no he was like this is
the painting you have to get
and i was like i'm down like that'd be
amazing
wow yeah
that'd be really good do that that
sounds great
darune olbain says tim watch farscape
show it's awesome
all right well that's after sg-1 i
suppose her escape was cool was it
it's not as proud
samuel brucker says so how do we let the
north koreans know that we love them and
that we believe that they are worth
saving can we drop millions of crates
full of kfc blue jeans and iphones
[Laughter]
that'd be a dream so there are
non-profits that i work with we send
outside information to north koreans so
i when i was in north korea one of the
turning points for me was watching movie
titanic
because i mean until then like love i
mean we don't learn like we don't know
right in north korea how did you get it
it's uh through the underground market
but you get executed
and sent to prison camp for watching a
foreign information wow yeah if you ever
read the bible you get executed yeah wow
so it's you're literally risking your
life to watching us a movie
like here we just do what netflix spin
your knight north korea
you can actually shoot it for titanic
[Laughter]
but you can actually watch some really
messed up stuff on the internet in
america like things you shouldn't watch
you can watch yeah
let alone the titanic you know yeah
wow no so i mean those kind of things
you can do like there are a lot of work
we can do to let them know
and i mean a lot of people are saying
like oh what are going to do like north
koreans are so brave once they think we
are monsters
but when i came to america like just
looking at you guys
lie doesn't have power
that's the thing we never have to be
worrying about these lies what's the
name of your non-profit that does that
it's oh i'm working with the human
rights foundation they have this uh
program called
flash drives for freedom okay so we send
this usb sticks with information
and somehow north koreans love
the beverly hills desperate wives wow i
don't know why
but because it's so different
so they want to escape their life i
think yeah did you want to look at that
that
interesting yeah
well to everybody who hung out on this
friday night and smashed that like
button thank you all so very much
subscribe to the channel
use the notification bell i guess it
doesn't seem to work so set an alarm on
your phone for 8 p.m every day over at
youtube.com teamcast.org you can follow
us on instagram and facebook at tim cast
irl you can follow me at tim cast and go
to timcast.com become a member we're
going to have a vlog up tomorrow over at
youtube.comcastcastle
which is what do we do this time oh we
went to um ziplining
and then this is this is really really
funny luke
blows up the house and nukes the planet
i'm not kidding literally the vlog is
luke
blowing up the house it's silly it's fun
you'll love it do you uh well i actually
i suppose you just shouted out your book
and your youtube channel already but do
you have any other social media or
anything else you want to mention oh
well i'm on like instagram twitter
facebook not on tick tock so no
find me on other platforms please just
youtube is good yeah it's called the
voice of north korea
yeah cool and then uh china uncensored
challenge chris you want to mention
anything
uh you can follow me on twitter at
xiaojung
s-h-e-l-z-h-a-n-g although to be honest
i've been
a little late on twitter lately but you
know it was good for the mental health
yeah yes
yeah and you can follow china uncensored
or america uncovered or podcast china
unscripted on youtube twitter
facebook instagram
not tick tock yeah that's right and you
guys can follow me on twitter at sour
passwords and thank you guys both for
coming on me i feel like i've speak for
many people when i say that your story
was incredibly moving you presented it
so calmly and so rationally that i think
that hopefully it will change a lot of
people's minds and of course chris and
shelly for your knowledge about china
thank you for having me three cheers for
you on me oh yeah yeah for sure
me your the story about how you risk
your life to watch a movie
how you face certain death even just
staying where you were and you had to
make your way to china how you endured
slavery because it was better than death
but how you traveled through the desert
to make it finally to south korea to
find freedom is one of the most
inspirational stories i've ever heard
and so i hope it inspires many americans
to stand up for what they believe in
to uh not allow ideologues and
authoritarians to take over because
certainly it can be it can be way worse
if we do nothing
and we have uh um
we have a lot to lose as a country
but
for the time being fighting back we
would never even risk as bad as as bad
as as it was for the things you've
experienced i mean americans their worst
case scenario will never be as nearly as
as devastating unless we do nothing
so i hope that's a good reminder and
thank you for coming i really appreciate
it yeah so uh everybody else thanks for
hanging out we will see you all monday
in the next episode and
have a good weekend bye guys
you